la vallée de front plusieurs projets
avec le prisme où il vient de monter une
pièce avec plusieurs dizaines de
comédiens amateurs saint quentinois venu
rejoindre ses comédiens professionnels
sur scène il est auteur associé au
théâtre du rond point à paris mais il
est aussi metteur en scène et comédien
il nous parle aujourd'hui de sa
résidence e fructueuse qu'il mène avec
le prisme et qui se poursuit la saison
prochaine voici pierre note dans le
kiosque
la résidence se poursuit la saison
s'achève mais la résidence s'achève pas
du tout puisque cette année on a donc
fait les présentations de sortir de sa
mère de la chair est triste au cul qu'on
a présenté ici en création on à
l'atelier avec le chien du rouge feu
rouge à un atelier avec les 7 marc les
ateliers des classes pack auquel on est
très attaché et puis ce soir s'est pas
véritablement une représentation c'est
une étape de travail
cette étape de travail précède la
création de kalachnikov aux treize vents
à montpellier fantomatique nationale et
au théâtre du rond point à paris
c'est une écriture complètement dingue
très trash très gore très sanglantes de
stéphane guérin est un jeune auteur 40
ans c'était une pièce extrêmement
violentes qui oppose une sorte de vomi
fulminant du monde contemporain du monde
des marques du monde de la télévision du
monde de l'information torturerait dans
tous les sens et obscénités par tous les
écrans et à la fois une visite
extrêmement audacieuse et virulente du
mythe antique parmi les premiers le
fait-divers originel le meurtre du père
par oedipe le marteau de lajos et le
suicide de la mère jocaste les sommes
sont dits ciel mon fils n'est pas à
votre fils chère madame est un loup et
deux qui font regretter les chiens bien
content de retrouver quand il t'as sorti
ton troubat cautionne ces nouveaux
autres qu'il est sorti est plutôt mal
embouché sangsues couleuvres je vais
t'arracher talent des serpents et de
faire bouffer dont venaient y faire quoi
qu'il en est bien sorti d'ailleurs en y
petit seulement sortie dans les airs est
déjà à pointer à jamais entre vos deux
nuits c'est un travail de ce qu'on avait
parlé l'an dernier puisqu'on avait
rassembler une équipe d'une cinquantaine
d'amateurs habitants de la région
amateurs de théâtre ou bien simplement
des spectateurs qui souhaitait faire
l'expérience du plateau c'est une c'est
une épopée dingue écrite pour 99
personnage là dont s'emparent 50 acteurs
mais chacun joue trois quatre cinq voire
dix rôle et jeu boulons interloire bola
mais pour gamins des hosties en leur
faisant croire que c'est ça le summum
d'école fric ce week-end j'aime écrire
on aime on ne compte pas lui faire de
peine il dalton bell pendant plaisir
c'est un projet impossible complètement
dingue
terriblement prétentieux et ambitieux et
puis c'est un groupe qui s'est formé ici
sur le grand plateau de du prisme
formidablement soudée en plus des gens
ont traversé des choses extrêmement
extrêmement douloureux et pénibles
difficile et ils ont tenu dans un projet
collectif formidable où chacun fait
entendre une voix très très différentes
pour servir un texte qui n'a aucun
intérêt que j'ai écrit et qui m'amuse
beaucoup qui plaît je crois regroupe des
amateurs mais qui n'est qu'un prétexte
pour pouvoir travailler ensemble
collectivement à créer une sorte de
moment complètement dingue autour d'une
épopée qu'on raconte là le chef du roi
ou cheveux rouges l'histoire d'un type
qui va s'emparer du pouvoir
depuis une terrible terrible mensonge
tous douce ils me regardaient de haut
comme on observe sa crotte avec les
goûts et les uns cordelle flotte encore
et résiste à la force centrifuge et
inspirant que la chasse d'eau tu as bien
résisté à la force centrifuge et
aspirante de la chasse d'eau mon amour
et la crotte fille est toujours pas cédé
disparaître tandis que toi mon chéri au
prodige tu es là vient d'accrocher collé
à la paroi une c'est la grandeur et la
décadence d'un la grandeur et de la
décadence d'un d'un monstre de pouvoir
en fait en fait eu très attaché à la
pièce mais des amateurs la lap la porte
ils sont quand même c'est quand même 45
sur le plateau apporter chacun des
personnages a joué tous tout le temps
ils sont tous présents sur le grand
plateau du début à la fin de la pièce
qu'il a duré à peu près deux heures
c'est une épopée c'est très rapide c'est
très vif
je n'ai jamais vu comme ça toujours si
calme c'est tout effacer tant et si bien
que quand il était là parfois on se
demandait encore où ils étaient ils
étaient juste là se faire si petit qu'on
ne le voyait pas et le voilà rssi droit
si grand si fort et qui bouffent le
premier conseiller de son fils en partie
seulement quelques parties voilà mes
yeux se brouillent et mes dents tremble
pas si l'ol déjà le précède comme une
ombre d'effroi et de silences qui seront
nous abat un flash
je sens en moi que tout ce droit se
brouillent celui qui fuit et voilà ça
devait arriver j'ai une petite dérive
angoisse ça permet à chacun de faire
l'expérience du plateau à chacun de
faire de faire l'expérience du théâtre
d'appréhender mieux cet espace au cip
qui appartient quand même absolument à
tout le monde c'est bien le théâtre de
service public dont il est question est
là pour le coup on travaille ensemble
sur des questionnements qui nous qui
nous touche tous la question du pouvoir
la question de la séduction l'adhésion
du mensonge c'est bien de ça dont il est
question est là à 50 personnes sur le
plateau s'empare de ces questions là le
tas du rond point est très très très
présent à elancourt au prisme qui est
une sorte de théâtre du rond-point de la
deuxième couronne comme le dit sabine
caussens je pense que c'est exactement
ça moi je suis auteur associé au théâtre
du rond-point suis très présent à
elancourt au prisme à saint-quentin
autour de projets qu'on veut mener avec
des lycéens avec les classes pas qu'avec
les classes avec les 7 mar avec des
groupes d'amateurs dont la coude à coude
hâtive avec les stages de formation
qu'on va convaincre organisé ici
cacahouète vous récompenser le bateau
on doit rester assis mais c'est vous qui
avez dit à cela si sa voix et voilà
c'est foutu what y apprend ça fait mal
c'est un travail de chaque jour qu'on
mène avec dominique ben haim avec sabine
caussens au prisme
et puis il ya évidemment le travail de
création qui est très important l'année
prochaine on présentera perdu dans
stockholm qui est une pièce que j'ai
écrites pour trois femmes sylvie laguna
chloé olivères s annonce est pas du tout
le haut niveau sylvie laguna juliette
coulon et brice hillairet qui était un
homme une place pour trois femmes dont
il est un homme qu'on présentera la
saison prochaine ici au prisme et
ensuite au théâtre du rond-point nouveau
sujet de la rédaction
sous la direction musicale de david
stern et sa compagnie opéra foucault le
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
présente le 7 juin un concert des airs
les plus emblématiques de mozart
interprété par 250 enfants issus
d'écoles primaires et collèges des
yvelines
ils deviennent le temps d'une
représentation devrait choristes j'aime
bien chanter je trouve que c'est bien
plus on apprend plein de change est
facile à apprendre
on commence à les répéter père prend les
approcher nous de temps en temps dans ma
chambre chante un peu d'autant qu'on
sent peu habitués à écouter des airs
d'opéra nous jeunes chanteurs
travaillent depuis plusieurs mois en
chêne répétition en classe et sur la
scène du grand théâtre
un projet qui demande un réel
investissement on arrive dans avec des
enfants sur des secteurs difficiles qui
sont qui deviennent passionnés voilà ça
vient aussi de l'enseignant qui est très
très moteur dans une dans une classe on
leur a expliqué l'histoire de chaque air
d'opéra ils sont venus au théâtre c'est
bien aussi qu'on vienne dans leur milieu
sont contents qu'on revienne dans leur
classe et
il nous montre aussi tout le travail
qu'ils ont fait autour de mozart en
l'occurrence pour cette année non c'est
passionnant
non
les enfants sont motivés ça fédère le
groupe ils deviennent beaucoup plus
concentrés ils sont attentifs ils sont
attentifs au moindre petit petite
remarque donc ça en classe pour les
apprentissages ça apporte beaucoup
curieusement même si les paroles sont
italiens ou en allemand ils ont beaucoup
de facilité à les apprendre plus que les
tables de multiplication ou les
conjugaisons et à partir du moment où
ils sont dans le projet et qui sont le
redis participer ils ont une faculté de
mémoriser beaucoup plus que les adultes
ça passe tout seul la mise en place de
ce projet et pour le théâtre l'occasion
de démocratiser l'accès à l'art lyrique
dans le cadre de son programme opéra
pour tous soyez généreux
d'accord mais généreux fait pour le
public pour vous l'objectif étant
évidemment au travers de ce projet de
faire des jeunes gens des spectateurs
avertis avant tout c'est de leur donner
des clés pour apprécier au mieux les
oeuvres et les oeuvres d'opéra notamment
est évidemment l'idée l'objectif c'est
d'en faire de futurs spectateurs de
futurs spectateurs autonomes dans leur
pratique à on pourrait imaginer c'est le
cas année après année on se rend compte
que nombre d'enfants en reviennent avec
leurs parents dans une pratique
individuelle une pratique de plaisir de
loisirs et on est ravi
oui
et encore quelques dates à retenir avant
de mettre de l'awacs sur votre planche
de surf le 14 juin vous pourrez
applaudir l'immense compositeur frank
kozik accompagné d'un choeur de saint
quentinois dans les spectacles le choix
des coeurs au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines tandis que les
blérots de ravel seront en concert avec
le spectacle jeune public
tôt ou tard le 20 juin à la merise
attrape mounira mitchala et hk les
saltimbanks seront quant à eux le 15
juin en concert devant le scarabée à la
verrière des dates que vous pouvez
retrouver un cycle l'ensemble de la
programmation culturelle des salles
saint-quentinoise dans le kiosque sur
internet aux adresses qui s'affiche
alors à bientôt bon spectacle et
n'oubliez pas que tous les mardis sur le
www.cadets.ca qui point fr vous pouvez
gagner des places de spectacle le coach
de l'as bages